[Music]
there he is
my boy
mommy dearest i know you said something
loose on this world
what was it i think you know
no stone unturned
my body
[Applause]
this family's unnatural behavior
i've never experienced anything like it
welcome back everyone it's charlie happy
comic con week this is going to be my
marvel hellstrom trailer breakdown i'll
explain what's going on with the series
there's a bunch of easter eggs in here
and dr strange ghost rider stuff so if
you're new to the channel there's still
a bunch of comic-con videos that i
haven't got to yet a bunch of trailers
and a bunch of really cool stuff
so be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there's also more convention
stuff that's going to be happening
between marvel and dc later this year
too
we'll do a new amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do
with the darker mcu characters like
ghost rider in marvel phase 4.
so if you have no idea what hellstrom is
or who the character is from the comics
what's going on with the tv show
this is sort of like the final tv show
from marvel studios older projects under
jeff loeb completed just as kevin feige
was starting
to take over all the marvel phase 4
avengers disney plus series
so this series is sort of a cross
between rosemary's baby in the omen
series if damian became a supernatural
detective like john constantine from the
dc universe
hellstrom is the son of the mcu version
of the devil in a human woman which
explains his powers
he was a member of dr strange's
defenders team the midnight
sons and he's a big ghostwriter
crossover character the woman walking
around with him in all this trailer
footage is his sister her name is satana
she's just like him but they gave her a
normal human name on the show
just shortening it to anna she has the
same divine magical powers through her
devil bloodline though
marvel's introducing blade into the mcu
vampires doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness is going to be the first real
mcu horror movie
they're doing a moon knight disney plus
series so marvel is just doing a lot
more
darker supernatural characters heading
into marvel phase 4.
kevin feige said the reason why they
waited this long to do characters like
this
in the mcu is just because they were
looking for the appropriate in
in dr strange provided that in the
reason why this is on hulu though
is because of a special ghost rider
supernatural marvel crossover event that
they were going to build up to
involving the ghost rider tv show that
they had been developing for the last
couple of years
it would have been like the next version
of the marvel netflix defenders team-up
show with daredevil luke cage jessica
jones and iron fist all coming together
but this would have been all these
different supernatural characters from
the mcu like hellstrom and ghost rider
teaming up it was going to be called
adventure into fear
the reason they're doing it on hulu and
not netflix or disney plus
is because it would have been way too
hardcore for disney plus
religious themed horror just way too
much for disney plus
not super family friendly and because
marvel ended its relationship with
netflix when they launched disney plus
and bought hulu they just put it on hulu
if you didn't know that
disney owns all of hulu now so that's
where they're putting all their hardcore
content that they feel like
isn't family friendly enough for disney
plus the hellstrom tv show is just one
of the few shows that survived the
merger between marvel tv
and marvel studios when kevin feige took
over all the tv shows
so pretty much all tv shows are coming
from marvel studios now
even though you wouldn't know it to look
at the trailer they took a lot of the
marvel branding out of this trailer
weirdly enough
they canceled the ghost rider tv show
with gabrielle luna's robbie reyes
version of ghost rider from agents of
shield a little while ago you probably
heard about that
it would have been his version of the
character from agents of shield going on
to his own series
remember way back in agents of shield
season 4 when he left at the end of the
season through one of those portals that
looked like one of dr strange's portals
talking about going to an alternate
mention this giant war that he was
fighting in the supernatural war
that would have all figured into what
was happening with the adventure into
fear
team-up series that they're going to do
on hulu and the writer wants to send
them both back to where they came from i
hope that means hell
hell is relative dimensions
space planets it's all connected
plenty of them qualify as hell
the earth is just one territory in a war
that's been going on forever
but it sounds like their plans have
changed so all those characters will
wind up showing up in the mcu like we've
been talking about an mcu version of
ghost rider during doctor strange too so
i'll address that in a second
but as they imply during the trailer
footage his mother was a human woman
this person here that seems like she's
been driven mad
you can see the childhood family photo
of them together with the devil's face
scratched out remember his father is the
mcu version of the devil that looks like
he just took human form to have this
family
prior to the series it's just implied
that he was banished back to hell at
some point
and when they refer to their mother
unleashing something on the world again
in present day
and you start to see them reference
their quote unquote father
you see all this violence erupting it's
just them teasing the return of the
devil
and it sounds like it's building up to a
big event in the finale with him and his
sister
trying to lock the devil back in hell
there was a point a little while ago in
the comics where doctor strange
considered hellstrom to take over as the
next sorcerer supreme because his
magical aptitude and innate divine power
was so great
in that way he's also kind of like the
legion character and that he has the
potential for
limitless power if he succumbs to his
darker side
as you can see in the trailer struggling
with that dark side of himself as a big
part of the series his sister
goes through the same thing too she's
just like him with the same types of
powers
the dynamic between them gets super
weird but they're mostly partners
so it's just a darker religious themed
marvel series on the road to blade in
the mcu ghost rider in the moon knight
character they'll obviously be more
supernatural characters in the mcu
that's just the beginning
he would be a good candidate for a new
marvel defenders or a midnight sons
blade team up in the mcu if they can
ever get to that
but kevin feige hasn't really said what
his larger plans are for the darker
marvel characters teaming up
i think we'll get a better hint of that
in doctor strange too multiverse of
madness with some teases for the other
new characters like
moon knight ghost rider that whole side
of the mcu the way that they explain his
power is also a lot like magic from the
x-men like you see magic in all the new
mutants trailers
marvel classifies hell as an alternate
dimension that the mcu devil rules over
and when hellstrom is in that dimension
he wields almost unlimited power
but while he's walking around on planet
earth his abilities are just limited by
his mortal form
it's just like magic being way more
powerful when she's inside the limbo
dimension
rather than when she's just walking
around on earth she's still powerful
when she's walking around on earth but
in limbo she's way way more powerful
i know there's a lot of questions about
how this is connected to the mcu will
this character show up in any marvel
movies or other series
the way they're treating it is kind of
like the new mutants movie
because another group produced it but
they're releasing it through marvel
studios
so for instance the new mutants movie
bunch of x-men characters it's a horror
film
but because kevin feige didn't produce
it himself it's not
technically connected to the mcu it's
only loosely connected and the
characters could always come back in
future projects because now they own all
the x-men characters again
right now doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness is coming out march 2022
sam raimi mr spider-man himself is
directing he's an awesome horror
director
he also filmed a few giant comic book
movies in the past you probably saw
pizza time
at the marvel phase 4 comic con panel
benedict cumberbatch said something
interesting too about the general tone
of doctor strange 2
given that they were talking about doing
an mcu horror movie i'm paraphrasing but
he said something like it was important
for them not to forget the humor
of the previous movie and when you start
talking about doing horror and comedy
elements together that's literally sam
raimi's origin story
[Applause]
obviously the hellstrom series is
playing it way more serious way more
hardcore
but all those episodes will start
releasing october 16th on hulu
i probably won't do weekly episodes just
because it feels like a smaller series
but i might do a video just to explain
where they end things after the series
is done
and just to be clear this is being
billed as a limited series so there will
not be
a season two marvel also skipped
comic-con
mostly this year with all their big
movie stuff so if you wonder why there
weren't any big marvel movie trailers
that's why
they'll do their own separate special
event for all the upcoming movies and
start releasing trailers
probably sometime late august or
september that's also when we're gonna
start seeing a bunch of the falcon in
winter soldier series on disney plus
it's supposed to start airing episodes
in the fall but that's
a pretty general date range it starts in
september
but they could push it a little bit
later if there are more delays the
avengers one division series is supposed
to start releasing
in december but it'll directly cross
over with doctor strange two multiverses
of madness in a way that falcon and
winter soldier will not
there was a bunch more big comic con
stuff and marvel stuff that dropped in
the last couple of days i'll try to do
as many videos for that as i can there
was a really cool
marvel wolverine documentary trailer
i'll probably do a video for that
sometime tomorrow
so as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you should see all those
videos when i post them
leave all your video requests in the
comments below and just everybody let me
know what you think about marvel doing
darker supernatural character series
will you wait for everything everyone
click here for that brand new justice
league snyder cut trailer
and click here for that avengers 1
division trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you